welcome back folks my name is love
agarwal with ibm
today i'm excited to share with you
netiza as a fully managed service on
cloud
so let me start with what netezza users
already know and what has always made it
the enterprise data warehouse of choice
things like speed simplicity and agility
the community loves these aspects about
natisa and while we have doubled down on
them to make them better users also
wanted to see a few new things to help
them modernize their data strategy and
bring data warehousing into the age of
cloud
users asked for
a fully managed price performance
offering that provides them with
on-demand elastic scaling and
consumption-based billing on public
clouds
we listened to this feedback and
incorporated it into netezza as a fully
managed service on cloud
this massively parallel processing high
performance cloud data warehouse runs
the next generation neteza database
engine this means users can now enjoy
the same hardened and performant netize
engine they trust to run their critical
workloads on and combine it with the
benefits of a cloud native solution
so let's talk about what's new
simplicity as a fully managed cloud
native offering netizza as a service
abstracts away the complexities of
optimizing the underlying resources
including cpu disk and network
infrastructure
users really only need two units these
being how fast you want to go
and how much data you need
everything else is fully abstracted and
managed by us
load and go with no tuning and no
indexing existing netiza customers enjoy
risk-free and frictionless upgrades with
a single command
granular elastic scaling
we have brought incredibly granular
elastic scaling capabilities to the
platform
this allows you to apply computational
power only when you need it
users select the performance
characteristics that meet their workload
requirements and can increase or
decrease performance as workload demand
ebbs and flows
you also have the ability to pause and
resume resources as needed as well as
auto pause to scale down when the
platform is idle
storage density can be increased
independently of performance demands as
capacity needs require
this is opposed to other offerings that
scale exponentially
with fixed t-shirt sizes leading to over
provisioning of resources and
unanticipated costs
our unique approach gives you linear
performance scaling and cost
predictability in the cloud you only pay
for what you need and when you need it
speed
netezza as a service is designed
specifically for running complex
analytics on very large data volumes
it's unique massively parallel
processing architecture combined with
hybrid columnar acceleration assist
delivers blistering fast query
performance on highly complex mixed
analytical workloads
sophistication
this one is all about operationalizing
data science and machine learning at
scale
netezza brings analytics to the data
its rich 200 plus built-in analytics
capabilities support all major languages
such as python r java and more
data scientists and analyst teams can
build models that operate on data
predict and score directly inside the
database instead of having to offload it
to a separate environment and deal with
the associated pre-processing and
transformations
for users ready to move from their
netezza appliances to the manage as a
service offering it could not be easier
upgrade risk free to netize as a service
with a single command
start enjoying granular elastic scaling
superior price performance and cost
predictability in the cloud with a
sophisticated cloud data warehouse that
provides best-in-class analytics
capabilities to drive your business
goals
talk to your ibm representative today to
take netize as a service for a test
drive and check out the links below to
learn more about our offering
you